bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va tester
un smartphone que je viens de recevoir
qu'elle avait plutôt sexy
un produit d'entrée de gamme c'est le
que j'ai omis raid mi5 plus et on va
regarder ça maintenant
dans la famille des produits d'entrée de
gamme il ya énormément de marques qui se
bousculent vous avez effectivement des
marques très connues comme samsung et
j'en passe et des meilleurs mais il ya
une marque continue vraiment de
progresser et qui devrait arriver en
france dès cette année et qui est
d'ailleurs a ouvert son premier shop à
marseille n'y a pas longtemps c'est la
marque dia ho mizio vie je n'ai déjà
parlé quand j'étais au mwc à barcelone
et là je vais vous en parler parce que
ce produit leurs ennemis 5 plus je
trouve plutôt cool en tout cas sur le
papier
j'avais hâte de prendre en main et de
voir s'il était bien c'est un produit
que je peux tester grâce à mon
partenaire iphone merci beaucoup à
l'iphone ça vous intéresse vous avez
ceux produits qu'ils revendent sur le
site de l'iphone donc ce qu'on va faire
c'est autant à faire une vidéo de hunt
boxing on va l'ouvrir
on va regarder tranquillement se caler
derrière on va regarder si le produit
est plutôt cool plutôt sexy
s'il a une bonne tête oui ou non si les
bosses il est pas beau s'en va le
regarder et enfin une deuxième vidéo une
vidéo test beaucoup plus complète ou là
effectivement on va aller gratter dans
l' os on va les voir si la surcouche de
guillaume y écoulent oui ou non on va
réaliser appareil est fluide s'il marche
bien c'est tombe bien s'il fait de
bonnes photos de bonne vidéo
on va regarder tout ça donc rester
connecté j'invite à vous abonner parce
que vous allez voir ça va être super
cool de toute façon on va faire
davantage de tests davantage d'infos sur
les smartphones sur l'attaquant rennais
général donc abonnez-vous bon et dès
maintenant si ce produit vous plaît je
vis tu as laissé tout de suite un joli
pot ce bon on y va on commence tout de
suite c'est parti bon voilà la bête le
yom ireny 5 plus on va commencer par
l'ouvrir pour l'ouvrir on va venir
chercher up le scotch ici voilà
ah ça c'est l'emballage qui fait pas
marrer review monsieur greuil afin de
poing comme merci ya phone voici donc la
jolie boîte du raid mi5 plus
alors moi je trouve ça cool parce que
j'aime beaucoup ce orange c'est
effectivement une couleur propre asia
omis je trouve très sexy je trouve que
comme d'habitude c'est quelque chose qui
tape vraiment à l'oeil qui est très
sympa globale vers sean voyez ici plutôt
sympa plutôt bien réussi on va l'ouvrir
et on va regarder ce que ça dit à
l'intérieur viens par ici m'ont copiée
voilà voyons voir ce que ça dit ah ça
j'aime bien sobre
qu'est-ce qu'on est si ça c'est pas mal
à regarder on ouvrirait après restants
j'aime bien commencer par les
accessoires comme ça on garde un peu de
suspense vous avez ici une petite
protection alors on va voir ce que ça
donne une fois dessus protection
plastique
on va très bien la place pour l'appareil
photo pour ici le port jack
bon je sais pas si ça va être très joli
au final on verra ça après next
voici ici ou là bates en voyait déjà en
termes de prise en main c'est vraiment
le modèle plus c'est vraiment très grand
modèle plutôt cool simple caméra ici ne
pas le disent a semblé promis je ne vais
pas le désassembler plutôt sympa plutôt
sympa maintenant on va regarder ce qu'il
y à ici là on voit effectivement qu'on
un grand écran va l'allumer tout à
l'heure on reviendra plus en détail tout
à l'heure en attendant on voit qu'ici on
a un port jack qu'est ce que c'est ça
c'est de l'infrarouge peut-être ça peut
y ressembler le petit bouton de volume
le bouton pour l'allumer ici le port
micro usb ici le haut parleur ou les
haut parleurs bien évidemment votre
emplacement ici pour votre carte sim à
l'arrière une caméra ici votre petit
flash ici l'emplacement pour dérouiller
c'est plutôt pas mal je trouve que
l'emplacement est assez naturel alors
c'est vrai que ça dépend de la taille
des mains de chacun - prenant comme ça
peut-être légèrement en dessous et
encore ça va ça ne choque pas trop c'est
une habitude à prendre je trouve qu'il
est plutôt bien placé effectivement le
fait que le flash là ça va éviter qu'on
est à gratouiller ici l'objectif connect
position des doigts dessus et comme de
toute façon c'est un modèle qui est très
grand dans le pire des cas je le
cherchais un peu plus bas mais je trouve
que ça va c'est plutôt pas mal fichu
c'est un produit qui comme ça paraît
quand même relativement lourd
de notre côté on est sur un produit
d'entrée de gamme va pas se mentir on
est sur un produit qui coûte quand même
moins 200 euros dont on voit pas non
plus lui demander la lune
il a un design plutôt sympa des bords
légèrement arrondi vous avez ici une
partie sur le haut voyez qui est
légèrement différente
on retrouve la même partie ici sur le
bas moi je le trouve assez joli voilà je
trouve qu'il fait le job
vous avez ici un dos en alu alors il
faut savoir qu'ici vous avez quand même
un écran 5.99 pouces c'est une dalle ip
est un écran 2160 par 1080 pixels
c'est du f hd + format 18/9 ça je vous
l'avais déjà dit à une résolution de 403
ppp le processeur est un qualcomm
snapdragon 625 octas core cadencé à 2
giga hertz vous avez intérieur soit 3g
et 32 gigas de stockage soit 4 gigas de
ram 64 go de stockage dans les deux cas
pouvait monter jusqu'à 256 giga côté
batterie je vous disais c'est une 4000
milliampères heures il a un appareil
photo de cette fille de 5 mégapixels ici
vous avez un appareil de 12 mégapixels
il peut filmer jusqu en 4k pas
stabilisation ça va pas être son fort
double lecteur 4 sim lecteur
d'empreintes digitales ici du microusb
je vous le disais on n'a pas dit ce type
c'est parce que ça coûte plus cher et ça
ne ferait qu'augmenter le coût de
l'appareil ce qui n'est pas l'objectif
de guillaume y c'est un produit qu'on
trouve en trombe de giguère à 185 euros
et en 64 giga à 199 euros
alors maintenant on va l'allumer à
petites vibrations
bonjour alors voyons voir première prise
en main la langue avant nous du français
parfait le lecteur d'empreintes
digitales bien évidemment pour connaître
mon doigt de tous les côtés choisir un
thème par défaut illimitée voilà la bête
ici on tourne sous android à sept points
un point de nougat surcouche et du m8 9
pointe de la surcouche à la casse pas
quatre pattes à un canard d'un point de
vue esthétique c'est très très très
sobre on cherche pas en mettre plein la
tête on en n'est pas plein la gueule
mais bon sur les et ça marche quand même
plutôt pas mal voilà donc voila un petit
peu l'idée de ce produit moi je trouve
plutôt bien donc on fera un test complet
un petit peu plus tard donc restez
connectés abonnez-vous je suis quand
même tester ça pour voir si c'est bien
ou pas parce que moi je le ferme d'un
point de vue purement esthétique je
trouve super joli comme ça j'ai bien
peur qu'on rajoute hausse à 7 viennent
tout particulièrement super moche c'est
de voir voyez c'est ça on va pas se
mentir vous rajouter cette espèce de
coques de protection tout de suite c'est
très très laid en termes de prise en
main ça glisse beaucoup moins forcément
ça coûte un peu caoutchouteux plastique
ça risque pas du tout de ce bar et ça
tient super bien on a pas de souci
là-dessus par contre voilà on perd un
petit peu le côté précieux du produit de
toute façon ces produits que ce soit que
j'ai omis ou un autre il faut les
protéger
c'est super important mais là c'est vrai
que c'est quand même tout
particulièrement super moche donc de mon
point de vue si vous voulez pas investir
de l'argent dans une coque c'est un
produit qui sont dus coûte pas très cher
vous voulez pas l'abîmer vous pouvez
mettre ça qui est livré avec mais
fondamentalement je vous conseille pas à
l'intérieur de la bad nous avons aussi
une petite notice raid mi5 plus avec ici
les petites infos le port usb haut qui
vous explique ici comment rajouter votre
carte sim votre micro sd vous avez ici
votre chargeur en micro et
mais qui est là et on y laisse des deux
côtés évidemment ici pour pouvoir le
brancher la petite pique ici pour sortir
les cartes sim et puis voilà c'est tout
ce que vous avez à l'intérieur un tout
le reste après celle hills et de la déco
c'est léger c'est joli attendant moi je
trouve ça plutôt bien réussi on va pas
se mentir il ya eu du bon bon travail de
fait là dessus du point de vue de
guillaumie que ce soit au niveau du
design que ce soit au niveau du produit
lui même
je trouve que le boulot est plutôt bien
fait point très positif 1 d'avoir ajouté
cette coque la même si elle est super
moche on va pas se mentir c'est quand
même hyper pratique et je trouve ça
plutôt bien dans l'absolu parce que ça
permet vraiment aux personnes qui ont un
smartphone qui achètent un smartphone
pas cher et que promis de mettre de
l'argent pour protéger leurs produits de
pouvoir le faire et à moindre coût donc
ça bravo
j'avais commencé à potasser et à réviser
un petit peu à regarder tout ça pour
réaliser mon test presse que je vous
publierait bien évidemment très très
très bientôt vous allez voir le xi a
omis up celui là il ya plein de choses à
dire et on va se régaler donc voilà peu
pour ces quelques infos sur ce xao mire
et demi cinq plus un grand modèle moi je
trouve vraiment cool je trouve qu'en
plus ce côté tarifs et les hyper bien
placé c'est plutôt bien des fois ce que
vous en pensez là c'est effectivement
une première vidéo de un boxing on en
parlera d'un petit peu à quoi il
ressemble s'il est sexy oui ou non s'il
tient bien dans la main oui ou non
donc là c'est effectivement une toute
première vidéo on va faire une autre
vidéo très très rapidement de test
beaucoup plus poussé beaucoup plus
détaillé où je vous dirais beaucoup plus
de choses dessus
bien évidemment vous invite à vous
abonner pour avoir toutes les infos sur
le xi a omis raid mi5 plus comme d'hab
de l'état mais c'est des jolies pouces a
marqué tous vos commentaires à me dire
ce que vous en pensez est ce que vous
aimez exeo me est ce que vous trouvez
que c'est une marque qui est intéressant
qui propose de bons produits oui non
est-ce que vous avez un que j'ai omis
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce
raid mi5 plus marqué moi tout ça en
commentaires qu'on en discute ensemble
bien évidemment comme d'habitude vous
invite à laisser deux jolies pouces
quant à moi je vous dis à très bientôt
pour les phases de tests et pour plein
d'autres vidéos vous allez voir qu'elle
est surprise car il ya plein de choses
super cool mais ça part un peu plus tard
d'ici là je vous dis à très bientôt
portez vous bien soyez sages chat
[Musique]